it's on YouTube racket man who has a
signature dance move of course I have a
signature dance me what is it what is it
it's uh in order to dance without
getting hurt I stretch so I just make
the stretching into the dance oh it's
called the lunge
no no it's sure yeah that'll be like
everything
[Music]
[Applause]
okay that's how I met Madonna
auditioning for ask you do you have one
they don't have one please do something
after that she said you were the best oh
that's why she said I pulled a quad so I
hope I'm not good top that let's see
so where is do I pronounce this Jimmy
Jame iCloud Jame I don't know this dance
what's it called the turkey it's called
the turkey okay you oh she's a
choreographer
okay Jame has created this dancers have
it's called the turkey when did you make
this up today long time ago so this
should be good then you've been working
on it have you selected and I should be
so lucky
okay I hope it suits the tree can you do
it on the step okay this is Jame giving
her her Turkey to Ashby Salah
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever have you ever got lucky
doing that not a dance move that's just
a turkey impressive
but when we're animal impressions you'll
be back now all rather all this is gonna
be good
where's drew Donald oh there's drew that
you are giving us too yeah
so the first one is prayer prayer catch
the flower okay
prayer prayer that's the flower okay and
what's the next one please sir
I've got a spider on my head okay okay
so what what kind of truck are you doing
them to spinning around oh okay
so toys that the first one you doing
prayer prayer first yes okay so so
here's the music
[Music]
[Applause]
in governs thespian now I'm not sure is
yours going to be quite like the turkey
it's not but it's a bit it's following
the same thing yeah this is the boneless
chicken dance you would do I have been
known to do it in club okay okay
this is Rihanna doing the bonus chicken
to better the devil you know
[Music]
[Applause]
no disrespect to the others but the
standards being took it to a different
was raised oh that is so so good amazing
that was good
[Music]
you